life has changed dramatically for all of
us since I was lost in the hand
Prince Harry speaking out from isolation
all in the name of veterans those
individuals that signed up chose to
serve then had life-changing injuries
they didn't stop there
and that's why it's incredibly
impressive but yet at the same time so
incredibly uplifting on Monday the Duke
of Sussex made a rare TV appearance via
video chat on the BBC series the one
show he's currently self isolating with
wife Megan Markel and their one-year-old
son Archie for Harry and Megan they've
had to get used to video conference
calling zooming and actually you know
that has had its advantages for them
because they wanted to retain close ties
to their British organisations and
charities and I suppose the Cogan 19
situation has accelerated that for them
and the royal couple is reportedly
staying at Tyler Perry's 17 million
dollar home in Beverly Hills here we are
everybody the One Show got in touch and
asked if I could shone a light on a
group of veterans that's lots of people
might not know about Harry listened to
stories from family members of World War
two veterans injured in battle in
particular soldiers who had received
then experimental reconstructive surgery
he was an amazing man he was sent down
to meet back in down in East Winstead
and really met him that evening McIndoe
said you need new upper eyelids new
lower eyelids you need a proper nose and
I'll give you a mouse suit what happened
Harry also provided this light-hearted
moment that's unbelievable
so when you when you met em can I ask he
had a proper tiara proper nose and and
good lips for kissing oh definitely the
surprise appearance follows a special
message Harry shared over the weekend we
should have also been gathering together
in the Netherlands to kick-start me
British games twenty20 in The Hague life
has changed dramatically for all of us
since I was lost in the hand his words
came in a response to the twenty20
Invictus games not kicking off that
weekend as scheduled
due to the corona virus pandemic I don't
do all of those in the Invictus family I
could have been well and supporting each
other through this challenge in time a
founder of the event
Harry praise the veterans and families
who participate in the games I continue
to hear amazing stories of families
coming together over online platforms
but please look out for those that have
gone quiet or that are no longer visible
on the chat sites you guys are the best
at this so I have no doubt that you're
all running around and supporting one
another the to digital appearances mark
a change of pace for Harry who's kept a
relatively low profile since
transitioning to life separate from the
royal family at the end of March there
was a lot of concern I'd just how
involved Harry would be with his UK
charities when he left Britain but in
fact I'm told and that he's very much in
touch with most of the charities and
organizations every week and phone calls
video conference calls he wants to hear
how these charities are doing he wants
to know how he might be able to help so
he's still very involved with these
causes he may be thousands of miles away
from us and over in LA but he's still
touching base very regularly with
charities and organizations but he's
worked with over here for you know in
some cases over a decade
[Music]